the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
in a minute I want we're going to go
through this exercise of key concepts
for the week but well with for you early
birds I offer and we may get to some of
this is there just something from the
week or the problem set just some topic
that's still bugging you that you just
don't do you just don't get and you'd
like me to put on a little listing where
I might get to it yes so if you have the
all of the terms the full velocity
expression in vector notation and you
want to know the acceleration of that
point just take the derivatives taking
care of all the rotating unit vectors
and all that stuff yeah where's the
Coriolis acceleration turn drop or is it
what is it fall out of I I can't I can't
answer it in words can't remember
exactly it actually but a Coriolis term
it does come curiously it comes from two
different places each part you know it's
to Omega R to Omega V rel kind of term
and it actually it comes from two
different places when you grind out the
derivatives of the velocity
so I'll the in terms of using the
general that's oh I remember now what I
want you to do and what partly what this
session is going to do is make you use
get you to use the acceleration formulas
enough that you have those discs
admitted to memory now we're going to
let you have crib sheets when you go
into quizzes and I would always have the
velocity acceleration formulas in polar
coordinates and in full vector form
right if you identify each of the terms
correctly that formula will work just
fine
getting the right components of rotation
rates can be a little tricky as you
might have found in that homework
problem from this week right you have
what is the in that time derivative that
of a rotating vector the Omega cross the
vector what Omega is that that's a
tricky that that you have to be just
careful with but I want but really get
remember if you remember the velocity
acceleration equations you can trust
them they will work as so we are okay we
can start now and I'll go back to my two
here so take that minute like we did
last time write down a piece of paper
two three four well you think of the key
concepts that were important in the past
week you know by important you need to
know them to do a good job on the quiz
coming up important concepts okay let's
make a list
polar coordinates and I'm going to
generalize that to call it
choosing coordinate systems it's an art
to that so but when to use them is
subset of that yeah yeah the torque
equation some of the external torques
vectors is d h dt and torques are always
with respect to some point so dhdt
angular momentum is with respect to some
point and the sec there's a second term
to this though and it is velocity of the
point in the inertial frame cross the
linear momentum in the inertial frame
no that one you haven't had to use it
much yet but that's the going to that's
one of the two really important Newton
law kind of things that we use in the
course sum of forces equals mass times
acceleration sum of torques equals that
okay I have another one rubadoux
rotating vectors
and taking derivatives rotating vectors
always boils down to eventually it's
down to cut you got to do the unit
vector so that's part of it how about
another one okay so I will generalize
that to essentially being able to write
a find equations of motion so from sum
of forces and right okay up anything
else
I think one it's not question I cart I
think is really really important one
you've been maybe you think we did it
last week I'd say being able to find
accelerations and moving coordinate
systems we did mostly velocities last
week but finding velocities and
accelerations in rotating and moving
frames okay so that's a pretty good list
I did if you'd asked me what I thought
the important things from the week were
that hits the important stuff okay what
we were talking about as people were
arriving is it and I might not get this
thing if we run out of time but does
anybody just got a burning question
about some concept that just doesn't
didn't work out for you our problem set
that came up or yeah
so that's really the derivative of a
rotation rate vector that was kind of a
nasty problem the first time you hit
that that's a that was new right let me
write that one down
yeah rotating frames and all that I get
if somebody else have another one right
oh yeah right
okay um let's anybody else a burning
question I think I'm actually going to
start there we're going to spend just a
minute on this this one and I did as an
example problem yesterday in the lecture
I basically did the same I had a rotor
here could have a disc on it just to
make it clear so this thing is rotating
at some Omega 2 and it was on a
merry-go-round going at some Omega 1 and
I'll pick a coordinate system here I
think it was Y X Z that I wrote in the
lecture notes and that's the rotating
one and so you have an O and an A here
and you have a fixed frame that but the
y one little ones attached to the
platform it's going around okay so the
rotation rate of the platform here is
what
in magnitude and unit vector Hardin mega
1k hat and does it matter which K
because they're both in their parallel
so the little K in the big K ok what's
the rotation rate of this shaft in terms
of a magnitude and a unit vector okay
Omega 2 and alcohol it at j 1 here will
just give it i it's hard to distinguish
my handwriting on the board between the
uppers and lowers so with z ones x ones
okay so it's in the j one direction
right and i've just intentionally made
it positive if we're in the other
direction you have a minus there okay so
now then the problem asked for the time
derivative of the rotation rate of the
spinning a problem that you fit in the
homework this thing was actually
inclined basically it's it's easy to
just say that you may total rotation
rate of the shaft
let's get that settled first in the
fixed inertial frame the total rotation
rate of this is what
yeah you can some rotation right so it's
Omega 1 K hat plus Omega 2 J 1 right and
I want to take the time derivative of
this Omega shaft total so it's D by DT
of these things so I can start to do
that so D by DT diz in this case is K
change the direction no problem
could that change could it don't work
yeah sure it me could be accelerating
right if it is then you get a term here
that comes from this one that would be
an Omega 1 dot k hat plus and now we
need to take the derivative of this
piece alright and that's now a rotating
vector and we've said that the
derivative of any rotating vector DQ DT
is the derivative of T as if the
rotation is 0 you know it's is its
magnitude increasing not its direction
changing plus Omega across Q I've
intentionally left subscripts and
superscripts off here because that's the
issue here what which ones go where
right all right so this is what we are
need to apply to taking that derivative
we've taken
we took this derivative and found this
term it was what gave us the Omega 1 dot
K and when taking derivative of this
what was the answer here zero because
the rotation rate is Omega 1 you're
crossing it more mega 1k cross with
Omega 1k that goes to 0 there's no
change in direction so we applied this
formula once to this now we're going to
apply this formula here so this I'll do
it this way so this is term 1
the term one gave us this term 2 is
going to give us this so apply what's
the take this take the derivative of
where we go here this guy now when I say
this is the say the partial derivative
of this thing
ignoring the contribution from the
change of direction so it's as if some
rotation were zero which rotation rate
Omega one good so what is the answer to
this piece of that derivative Omega 2
dot what direction same direction right
now we want to apply this piece and so
now the question comes down plus some
Omega cross with the Q and what's the Q
in this case two so this is omega 2 J 1
hat that's the coming from here that's
what this piece is so now we need what's
crossed with it hmm
what not so this is like I'm trying to
think of a clearer way to help you what
is causing its direction to change right
that's the one you care about what's
causing its direction to change is
causing this thing to come up and its
direction is changing because the
platforms are moving and so it's a mega
one K cross J so K troske J gives you K
cross J negative i1 in the rotating
frame right this whole thing Omega 1 dot
K plus Omega 2 dot J 1 plus now this is
the - actually we said - Omega 1 Omega 2
K cross J is I 1 hat ok and finally how
do you deal with the fact if I this
rotor had been on an inclined angle some
fee which is now this is the exact
problem that was on homework so proposed
a way of attacking that changes this
problem just a little bit
no you don't change the reference frame
you can you still have a coordinate
system and this you know you work with
the cordons you got in which reference
frame
yeah the movie one that makes it easy
because this thing now has it has a
vector Omega 2 like that and you can
break it up and do a piece like that and
a piece like that so now this and if
this is fie Omega 2 cosine fee is the
side right well make it 2 sine Phi is
outside what direction is it
what's its unit vector direction this
piece K okay and we're going to end up
crossing it with this term right so K
cross K nothing so in fact this bit
doesn't change in direction as it's
rotating does it so it isn't going to
contribute to that second term only
piece you have to be concerned with is
this one so down in here
right in this part of it all you would
do is say Omega 1 K cross and now you
just put in the full Q full Omega 2
which is Omega 2 sine K plus Omega 2
cosine sorry about the writing here and
you know do the cross-product you find
out that term disappears and you get an
Omega 1 Omega 2 cosine and this term
here this is still the answer but you
end up with a cosine feed in here
because it's just a component of a mega
- that's in the j1 direction now that
contributes ok great good that help
all right let's I'll leave this let's
get on to the problem for the day
problem for the day is you've got a
rotating arm of a mass sitting on it the
arm can is rotating at some rotation
rate Omega might have an acceleration
Omega dot theta double dot
this mask and slide so the problem is
this thing is where I'll start here so
it's rotating like this and eventually
the thing begins to slide and in fact if
I do it it actually works a little
better here because I have a little tiny
groove in this it helps a little bit so
it's rotating like that eventually
begins to slide the rotation rate is
slow it slides down if I made the
rotation rate fast enough slides up
right and and the angle at which it
happens clearly depends on rotation
rates accelerations the angle friction
coefficients and things of that sort so
what I want you to start with is here
it's basically a drawing of it and don't
want to give you any excess information
what I want you to do is each by
yourselves take just a minute and draw a
Freebody diagram of this problem and
then after that I'm going to have you
get in groups and improve on it but
start yourself draw a Freebody diagram
that will divide this mass on this thing
plank okay we've got it
got a sketch with a little Freebody
diagram on it but I want you to do now
we're going to use to do this two or
three times today
get in groups of four or five here
compare notes and come up with a group
Freebody diagram so you're pretty you're
you're pretty close
let me look where was your guys solution
again
there's maybe about a good as it gets
so these are mass I think everybody had
an mg almost everybody had a normal
force
everybody had a friction force some
discussion about what direction the
friction force ought to be in I'll draw
it uphill here and I'll call it f T for
tangential here and so some had about
that much there's a very important
missing piece which actually several
groups had what is that made guess what
I'm what's on your group three of your
groups had something on here that I
don't have up here yet I hear
coordinates kind of really need you this
one you can almost get away with not
putting in the coordinate system first
but you usually need to have a
coordinate system in order to determine
the direction of the forces okay I'll
get to that in a second so everybody
that I saw I had written down I saw a
number of little X Y Z frame sitting out
here like that maybe one that was lined
up not sure most not most like this it
was polar coordinates a good choice for
this from why not
so the question is whether or not R
theta and Z can de completely describe
the motion in the problem the race is
changing but that's known as our dot our
dot can handle the motion of this this
way our double dot can handle
accelerations this way theta ik dot can
handle this motion theta double dot can
handle that acceleration actually and is
there any Z motion or Z forces no make
sure you say polar coordinates Alire
just fine so you definitely have to pick
a coordinate system and so we're going
to use have an R hat system and theta
hat in this direction because in this
problem you really want to have a good
whether you use x and y as x and y is a
rotating frame here or R theta you want
to pick your coordinate systems so that
these things break down easily in this
case the normal equation will be in the
theta hat direction the sliding
direction will be in just one unit
vector direction so you don't have
multiple components in this direction if
you use that coordinate system to
describe this motion you have x and y
terms makes it harder so this is pretty
good coordinate system to use so that's
a really important missing piece is the
coordinate system if you don't have it
and as an aside about free body diagrams
free body diagrams right so my D is
turned around how do you know that the
friction force is in that direction you
had to assume something
you actually catch such trivial problem
you kind of figure out your head I gave
the demonstration and slid down but also
I said you do it fast enough it goes up
right so you don't really know so you
have to you have to have made an
assumption about about it and norm so
the general rule is to assign sine or
assumed positive values for all motions
and then you deduce the direction of
forces and I'll take a quick another
quick aside here to drive to illustrate
this in a problem that's works better
than the current one for this obvious
coordinate system for this little mass
on rollers inertial frame here's an X
and I asked you to do a Freebody diagram
of that
well you'd show me a normal force you'd
show me an mg but now I ask you to tell
me the direction to draw the spring
force so if you just if you if you adopt
the rule that for each body you're
working with you assume that it has
positive x positive x dot positive Y
positive y dot then you can deduce what
direction of the forces would result
sonar so in this case the only motion
that crew generates a force appear is
what
is X X dot X double dot only for only
motion that will generate a force is
displacement because it generates a
force where in a spring if they add a
dashpot here then velocity generates a
force too but displacement if you assume
that its placement is positive then
which direction is the spring force okay
so then you have spring force this way
and that's value KX and when you write
it into the equation of motion you put a
minus sign to account for the direction
of that arrow okay so in this problem we
kind of and you know if you ever do it
wrong if you pick this direction wrong
what happens in the answer well we still
get the right answer if you're
consistent it'll just you'll get another
negative sign popping up fix it okay
next so that's I think we're in good
shape now I'm going to draw the friction
force uphill because I'm going to assume
this thing's got to slide down and I'm
going to simplify the problem a little
bit for you and I'm going to say that
there's no angular acceleration constant
angular rate the distance that the mass
starts off up the slope is a one and a
half feet the and so it's going up like
this and it eventually reaches 50
degrees and at 50 degrees it begins to
slide downhill so it's going up a
constant rate and starts to slide point
is so there must be some friction
coefficient that provides a system with
the property sets that it slides at 50
degrees so the problem here is to find
the coefficient of friction so now
you're in your groups solve the problem
and I what I really want you to do is
come up with an expression mu equals in
variables and constants don't get don't
get around don't bother plugging it
numbers in that and I said well if
you're comfortable using polar
coordinates I'd be the way to do it but
you need to write some equations now and
I suggest you need to think in terms of
equations of motion I think it's time to
to go to back to come back together here
and work on this two three four groups
are sort of struggling with this and
it's because you're not really going to
first principles and doing the problem
step by step you're sort of jumping to
the answer because it's a trivial simple
Mickey Mouse problem that you did in
high school and so you're I'm kind of
pounding on you a little bit we give you
a simple problem so we can do them in a
short period of time but you need to
learn to do them in the rigorous way so
that you learn the real fundamental
stuff that you have to know this it's a
none of you you all have sort of
thinking about well we got some forces
here we've got an acceleration there but
nobody is just sitting down and saying
that some of the forces is equal to the
mass times the acceleration and work in
the problem out okay bad dog
just because this problem is almost a
statics problem doesn't mean you when
you have statics from when things are
statics problems it just means an
acceleration goes to zero and the sum of
the forces is now zero and you solve the
problem start with Newton's this case
it's moved in second law and it helps to
know an expression for acceleration so
you don't have to grind it out so we're
polar coordinates works pretty well in
this problem and I want want you to
commit to memory to acceleration
equations one in polar coordinates and
the one the general vector one so in
polar coordinates the Moyne that i
memorize is a with respect to o plus r
double dot minus R theta dot squared R
hat
plus our theta double dot plus 2 Omega r
dot theta hat Coriolis or Larian
centripetal and your linear acceleration
what's this term why is it what's it
doing there yeah but the reason I
remember it is we we in this subject in
this course we break down every dynamics
problem we're confronted with in two sub
problems that can be solved as the sum
of a translation of a body plus a
rotation and so this expression allows
you to write down the acceleration of a
point on a body which is both
translating and rotating what this term
accounts for the acceleration
contributed by what
then just so I've got this general let's
see I got a merry-go-round that's honest
you know on hunt wheel and it's rolling
along here and I have an inertial frame
and I got a point a here but now I've
also got a system in here which I'm
describing with an R theta connected to
this this thing can have translational
acceleration that's that term this
problem doesn't happen to have that it
goes to zero in this problem that's a
zero in this problem we can now apply
this equation to that problem
how many sub equations are we going to
get and why not three I know you said
two but I'm asking you why not three and
they Z which you need because it
describes theta dot so you have a Z
direction but is there any forces in
this problem in the Z direction are
there any accelerations in the Z
direction oh so you get a trivial answer
there so you can just write that one
down mass times acceleration equals zero
and there's no forces so there's three
possible equations only two of them are
meaningful in this problem and we
haven't one that we can summon the r hat
component and one in the theta hat so
the sum of the forces in the theta hat
direction for this problem
are what
from your Freebody diagram the normal in
the positive theta hat direction and
minus mg and is it I think it's
precaution data that's your theta hat
and is what is the acceleration in that
direction while you go to acceleration
formula and now let's inspect the terms
this one's zero because the platform is
is fixed R double dot zero because we're
just waiting this two pointed we're
waited to trying to calculate when it
begins to slide our theta dot squared
not zero our theta double dot not well
it might be but I said Omega dot zero
constant so that one's zero for this
problem and this term Coriolis 0 because
our dot is zero that's we're really
treating this like a statics problem it
hasn't started to move yet so the only
left with one term here so the sum of
the forces in the normal direction which
is the theta dot direction theta hat
direction are zero and that allows us to
solve for the normal force so you need
that you need Newton's law to find the
normal force to start with and you need
the normal force to find the friction
force so now let's do the sum of the
forces in the R hat direction and that's
going to it may be let's do the
acceleration first it's the mass times
the acceleration in the R hat direction
that's the mass and now what's the
acceleration these are the are directed
terms we have one one term right minus R
theta dot squared
no other terms and those have got to be
equal to the external forces in the
radial direction and what are they from
the free body diagram plus or minus plus
mu n but we know n is mg cosine theta
okay what else
minus mg sine theta all right
you could you can now that you know
everything in this expression you know
given theta dot you're given R you know
mg you know you'd given theta you could
solve this expression from you right
and the mg comes to goes to the other
side and you have a minus R theta
squared notice the MS cancel all the way
through right so mu would looks like it
equals to me G sine theta minus R theta
dot squared all divided by what G cosine
theta this this break these two apart
this gives me a tan theta minus R theta
dot squared over G Coase they two that
has units of acceleration G has units of
acceleration this is dimensionless the
answers got to be dimensionless so
see there's your answer but you really
had to use the equations of motion okay
now there's another thing I want to
address because I heard that pop up two
or three times do not confuse
accelerations with forces Newton's law
second law makes it really clear where
each one goes the sum of the external
forces go on one side of the equal sign
the mass times the acceleration goes on
the other so don't let don't get the two
mixed up
solve for the accelerations if you can
plug them in and multiply them by mass
and now you have that one side of the
equation the free body diagram
the only vectors that should show up on
a free body diagram are what forces the
real forces in the problem so in that
problem and that free body diagram there
is no R theta dot squared term doesn't
belong there and that will keep you from
making these sign errors and things like
that so the business about this thing
comes up - because it's - right out of
the acceleration equation all right what
would happen if I had not allowed if I
had not made the where go this term zero
I allow this to have some angular
acceleration to it that's what's got it
yet so it's got to happen - well you
don't have to do it if it's if it's kind
I can't do it concentrate but if you can
make this constant rate fast enough it
goes up right so even if it's
concentrate fast enough this thing will
slide up the thing immediately when you
start it almost immediate art down here
gee the friction force is pretty high
and the friction force course diminishes
as you get further up and eventually it
takes off right that's because that
minus R theta dot squared that's a
centripetal centripetal acceleration in
and if you don't provide the force that
causes that centripetal acceleration to
happen it says I want to leave town now
how about though if I had angular
acceleration as well if I have allow
angular acceleration this problem how
does it change the two equations that we
wrote weird what does it change which
side to change the forces does it change
the Freebody diagram not a bit changes
the acceleration side of the equation or
what term and now turns up you didn't
have before this one so now you have a
dynamic term in the theta hat equation
and it comes into into this expression
for some of the forces in this direction
and you would end up equals to M R theta
double dot
now it's an entirely different problem
it's it gets a little harder to solve
okay but good you know really good
fundamental practices F equals MA and
write out both sides carefully and then
you won't make sine mistakes and so
forth Thanks
good to see you